CAP.
CONTINUING RESOLUTION IS ONE
THING.
A BUDGET DEAL IS QUITE ANOTHER.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE FARM, THANKS.
G.O.P. LAWMAKERS ARE TRYING TO
COBBLE TOGETHER AN IMMIGRATION
PLAN BEFORE THE NEXT DEADLINE
HITS.
PETER DOOCY IS AT THE G.O.P.
RETREAT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THERE IS REASON TO THINK
REPUBLICANS TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AT THIS RETREAT HAVE
STARTED TO DELETE SOME
PROVISIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
OTHER REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THERE
IS NO TALK ABOUT AN IMMIGRATION
DEAL THAT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
AND BORDER SECURITY, THAT MAY BE
THE BEST WE CAN HOPE FOR.
>> THE PRESIDENT TOLD SENATORS
HERE IN WEST VIRGINIA TODAY HE
WANTS MORE FROM A ONE-FOR-ONE
BILL THAT ADDRESSES DACA ON THE
BORDER IS NOT ENOUGH.
>> WE WANT PEOPLE COMING IN TO
OUR COUNTRY BASED ON MERIT AND
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND
WE DON'T WANT VISA LOTTERY.
PICK A LOTTERY TICKET.
WE WANTED ON MERIT.
BECAUSE HE LACKS WHAT PEOPLE IN
IMMIGRATION IS GOING TO PLAY THE
MIDTERMS.
>> THE OTHER SIDE FRANKLY WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE NOTHING HAPPEN IN
CAMPAIGN AGAINST IT.
AND FRANKLY I DON'T WANT A BAD
DEAL.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A
DON'T DO IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
COME TOGETHER AND GET A DEAL,
THEN THERE MAY NOT BE IDEAL PAD.
>> CONTROL THE CONGRESS IS IN
THE ONLY THING HANGING IN THE
BALANCE.
FIGHT.
THE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL SAID TODAY HE
DOESN'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE AGAIN.
HE THINKS DEMOCRATS LEARNED
THEIR LESSON.
>> I DON'T THINK WE WILL SEE A
THREATENED GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
SAYINGS IS THERE IS NO EDUCATION
IN THE SECOND KICK OF A MULE.
>> THAT MEANS McCONNELL THINKS
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO LOOK THE
OTHER WAY AND VOTE TO KEEP THE
GOVERNMENT OPEN NEXT WEEK EVEN
IF THERE IS NO DACA DEAL IN
PLACE, EVEN THOUGH THAT'S WHAT A
LOT OF THEM THOUGHT HE WAS
PROMISING WHEN THEY AGREED TO